ja wirklich was besonderes ist gestern
nicht passiert zumindestens inhaltlich
olaf scholz hat das alles wieder ganz
souverän weg moderiert auch bei
kritischen fragen bezüglich des wirecard
skandals hat er gesagt daraus müsse man
lernen außer größten großen skandalen
keine persönlichen konsequenzen ziehen
sondern daraus lernen und die
kontrollsysteme verbessern das was er
immer sagt eine situation war dann aber
doch besonders da gab es nämlich einen
crash lauten krach während der sendungen
da können wir einmal reinhören was da
passiert ist und dass wir im 19
jahrhundert so abgebogen sind dass wir
eine tradition die eigentlich aus dem
mittelalter kommt die handwerker
ausbildung übertragen haben in die
moderne welt der
betriebe der fabriken und der
bürogebäude das gibt's nicht in vielen
anderen ländern der welt und die
beneiden uns alle darum deshalb müssen
wir auch jedes jahr wieder neu dafür
werben dass das tatsächlich funktioniert
deshalb müssen wir jedes jahr dafür
sorge tragen dass viele unternehmen sich
entscheiden auszubilden und viele junge
leute überzeugen dass sie den weg auch
gehen sie haben sie glück hat es auch
gerade irgendwie gescheppert ist
wahrscheinlich was umgefallen nichts
ernstes wir können mit den fragen weiter
mal unten kraft dort während der sendung
gehört das klang zuerst nicht wirklich
identifizieren wenn man hat aber ein
bild gesehen da ist eine kamera drohne
außerhalb dieser kultur werft dieses
veranstaltungsgeländes lang geflogen hat
ein livebild für die sendung geliefert
und ist dann gegen das gebäude geflogen
der pilot hat die drohne gegen das
gebäude gesteuert und eben abgestürzt
was dann für die lauten geräusche
während der sendung gesorgt hat wir
haben danach auch dann mit dem piloten
gesprochen da wurde uns gesagt da
mussten dann propeller ausgetauscht
werden danach konnten die drohne aber
weiter fliegen und es wurde wohl niemand
verletzt olaf scholz hat das aber ganz
fokussiert weg moderiert sich von dieser
kurzen schrecksekunde nicht aus dem
konzept bringen lassen sondern er fast
gegen den lärm angeredet danach haben
wir noch mal kurz darauf angesprochen da
hat konnte er nur drüber lächeln dachte
eben zuerst vom moderator gesagt wurde
da wäre eine kamera der wende lampen
gefallen das ist dann aber eine drohne
waren anbieten darüber aufgeklärt und
danach ging es dann wieder zurück nach
berlin jetzt sind wir hier vom
kanzleramt olaf scholz gerade schon
angekommen werden um 39 ist wieder
kabinettssitzung und dann hat heute
nachmittag wieder einen
wahlkampfauftritt in potsdam und
ansonsten heute wieder entspannteres
wahlkampfprogramm dafür aber stressiges
finanzminister